Donald Trump frequently asserts that he destroyed
ISIS, that of course the decision he made
to pull us troops from Northern Syria was
a good one.
Despite concerns from actual foreign policy
experts in generals that ISIS would immediately
reenter and that it would be disastrous for
the Kurds.
And case in point, we are now learning that
ISIS has started to quote reassert itself
what a nice word in both Iraq and Syria, they
have a new leader, a former Jenise cider of
the Yazidi people.
This was based on a report submitted to the
United nations security council and it says
that ISOL as they know it, uh, after losing
a bunch of territory physical territory has
started to reassert itself in the Syrian Arab
Republic and in Iraq, they're doing more insurgent
attacks.
They're calling and planning for breaking
out, uh, ISIS fighters from detention facilities
exploiting weaknesses in the security environments
of both countries.
Adding quote the borders between Iraq and
the Syrian Arab Republic remain inadequately
secured.
This report was based on information from
a bunch of different UN member States, and
it shows that a lot of those States are assessing
that the new leader of ISIS is a mere Mohammed
Syed Abdol Rockman Al Mahwah.
I'll Mala, I hope I pronounced that correctly.
So there's really nothing surprising here.
And to be clear, this doesn't mean that the
United States needs to be involved forever.
This doesn't mean the United States has a
responsibility or a right to be the world's
police.
It does confirm the absolutely aimless and
confused nature of Donald Trump's policy,
though he brags about taking out the leader.
Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi died in October, but
the reality is a new leader just comes in
and in this case, the new leader was literally
the second in command to Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi.
Donald Trump insists that everything's all
set.
He regularly says things as at rallies like
this, which was back in 2019
thanks to the global coalition, including
all of you here today and to our other partners,
the ISIS caliphate has been decimated.
Nobody thought it was possible to do it this
quickly.
Three weeks ago I was in Iraq and I was talking
to some of our great generals and I gave them
the absolute, go ahead.
I said, go at it, how long it will it take
once you get started?
He said, Sarah one week,
Trump claims endless then and now and all
the time and yet the actual reports from real
people who understand things confirm that
ISIS is surging as was predicted would happen
that ISIS is reasserting now.
The questions about us foreign policy are
far more complex just because we could predict
that what Donald Trump was doing was going
to lead to a resurgence of ISIS, which I've
been telling you about for a year at this
point or longer.
Is it the responsibility of the United States
to destroy ISIS?
I don't know.
I mean on the one hand we can't be the world's
police.
We can't just be constantly militarily in
endless numbers of countries for indefinite
periods of time.
On the other hand, ISIS grew in part because
of a vacuum that was created by our own foreign
policy decisions.
So aside from a general philosophy of interventionism
versus non interventionism, there are real
questions when we are part of creating a problem
and remember that taking away territory and
killing leaders does not root out the ideology,
which is much more difficult to fight in something
we've spoken to experts about on the program.
So this is admittedly complicated stuff.
It goes well beyond the capability and knowledge
of Donald Trump.
But to add to a complicated situation, a clueless
and arrogant president is very much the last
thing that we need.
So the headline, despite Trump's claim that
it's all over, we've defeated ISIS, we got
this leader, we got that whatever ISIS is
growing, once again, they are reasserting
themselves.
They reportedly have 100 million us dollars
in their reserves and the ideology, most importantly,
uh, is very much alive and well